I think it's a different question
whether they're there they're irrelevant
or out of business I I think and and
they certainly had admit this this also
that they're in a deeply deeply
problematic and perhaps intractable
business environment for newspapers you
know the times is on on one level
different from all other newspapers but
on the other on another level absolutely
the same the economics of the newspaper
business are not different the New York
Times than they are for the Chicago
Tribune which is in bankruptcy as are so
many big city newspapers so i think i
think the New York Times has a has a
sort of a Hail Mary strategy which is
which is that they will somehow leave
their their their physical body and and
they will they will migrate in an act of
transubstantiation to the to this new
electronic world the problem with this
new electronic world is that it doesn't
support what what it costs to support
the New York Times and again here they
are in this in a in the in the Hail Mary
mode of basically saying well maybe at
some point in the future it will support
now there's no evidence to to indicate
that and no sense of how long it will
take to get to that point when it might
support a a news gathering budget of
three hundred million dollars a year so
it'sit's this is nothing less for the
times and not just a business crisis but
but an existential crisis Being and
Nothingness with nothingness a very real
possibility
well I think it will reduce a readership
online by buy something on the order of
90 or 95 or ninety nine percent so it's
it's it's I you know another existential
moment what does the New York Times
become without its readers and I mean I
think you can say well yes but there are
still a million people who read the
paper every day in in paper form but
that's an that's an odd rationale
because then it sort of cancels out that
other view that we would of
transubstantiation into this new
electronic world I you know again I
think it's a it's another one of the the
the Hail Mary process at the times we
were going to to to morph into this
electronic product and we sort of have
but that's not doing it for us either so
now will suddenly try to charge for it
and maybe that will work I it's it's
it's a it's a it's a position that I
it's it's it's a non-business like
position it's just at this point wishful
pneus
it's very clear where people are getting
their news they're getting it online I
mean in the last number of years we've
been witnessed two and participated in
the profoundest change in the possibly
in the history of the news business that
that news consumers have largely
abandoned a traditional news outlets for
for electronic delivery either on the on
a pc or on a on a digital device a
handheld device or or through the myriad
of new new delivery forms and mechanisms
so people are not getting less news
quite the opposite i think i think
they're getting more news i think this
is for for a news consumer rather a
golden age you get you get you get more
you get it quicker you get it cheaper so
what could be bad and I would argue that
for the consumer nothing is bad for the
producer it's a it's a it's much less of
a of an optimistic time